you mentioned in the book show me the
funny that you were pleased with many of
the writers with whom you interviewed
because you felt that they stopped with
their typical PR pitch and you got them
to really let down their guard and and
some of them spent like 3-4 hours with
you oh yeah well you know again when we
first started talking about any of your
writers that the interview is such a
difficult way to get things out of
people because they it's very easy to
romanticize himself when you've achieved
a lot and talk about the way you wish
you work or think you might have worked
and we wanted to know how they worked so
by doing this different format having a
process-based interview where we said
work we'll watch a lot of the writers
combatted themselves and how different
this interview felt and one of the
things that we found interesting was
almost everyone at some point talked
about being anxious I mean these are
really top professional writers none of
them had any difficulty doing it but
they all said you know I'm going to come
up with something here and then it's
going to be compared to all my top level
Pearson I wanted to look good I want to
feel good about what I did and it was we
were stunned at how good they were I
mean every one of them was just such a
good pro and they just stuck issued
forth and when we would stop and ask him
questions or say well could you also do
this could you also to do that sure they
just pivot on a dime and just go
somewhere else I really think other than
the postgame questions you know we had
another word other than interview
they're almost not they're really not
interviews we just don't have another
word they're like Boyer isms for us we
just watched I mean you know sometimes
we got involved sometimes we didn't when
there were partnerships when we
interviewed partnerships we almost never
said anything we may be prompted but I
think the miracle in this book is that
it disproves this idea that so many of
the so-called screenwriting gurus
like mickey and troubie and these guys
come up with it there's only huh
seafield well say this kind of back in
the 80s but and the irony of said field
is that he never wrote a narrative
script he was a documentary filmmaker so
and the process is a reverse than that
but they always say there's one way to
do it and of course there's this book
proves that there's 25 ways at least and
that's pretty cool and to take to take
the same exact premise which is generic
really and to make 25 different stories
out of it was just so cool to be a part
of one of the things that's been really
nice is that we've gotten a lot of
writing professors around the country to
use the book with their students and the
thing they say they really like is again
watching these people create and more
than that a lot of them narrate as they
create so they're literally saying okay
I need to heighten the conflict here so
what I'm going to do is I'm you know the
yes it's a mother and her daughter yes
they love each other but I'm going to
make them more competitive because
that's going to do it or I'm going to
make one so stuck with her case and this
one's so stuck with her taste and both
feel so she were there right then said
they would tell us what they were doing
as they did it and so these kids are
finding a great because these people are
saying okay here are the problems you
run into here are some ways to possibly
fix it and you're watching these people
do it is miraculous any other tips for
putting your quote-unquote subject for
lack of a better word at ease was there
any self disclosure I know in therapy
sometimes they do that mmm you know what
Jeffrey was saying before um d we had
some movie writers in some TV writers
and the TV writers are pretty much used
to working in our writers room and so
one of the things that we try to do is
create that feeling as much as possible
so there were cases where somebody you
would get kind of pensive and we think
well let's make a suggestion and see
what they would do with it let's ask
question to see if it would jog
something so it was kind of cool that we
got to interact and and keep them
comfortable with always something going
there were never any dead spots and
these people are ever seen those kids
toys that you wind them up and they
bounced into the wall and then they turn
direction and go somewhere else to hit a
PDF furniture leg that grow some they
were like that it's like sometimes they
just need to the smallest question all
of a sudden boom they only come off
again does this remarkable to see like
the Schwartzes enjoyed listen yeah
cousin Bob or Uncle Bob yeah just saw
that they really went there all the
sudden it was awesome right I can't
exactly and and also I think like
Hollywood history came out of that
interview that probably wouldn't have
come out of a normal interview because
what made you're looking at really
edited down interviews because the as
you said they went on three hours and
what you're looking at is about 40
minutes of a three hour interview
because the mob let us put the dirty
stories in yeah but that story about Bob
Hope and Jack Benny and how after the
war he decided he didn't want it to
Sherwood didn't want to write jokes
anymore I mean I don't believe that any
of that would have come out in a regular
interview because we might not have
asked the question but something he said
about his history made him think of Bob
Hope and about Jack bat and that Jack
Benny it was George Burns well quite a
few of the writers made that comment
that he said yeah we get interviewed a
lot but we're telling stories we
normally don't tell because of the
nature of the interview in the place
where it went so that was kind of
fascinating for us
you